huh all right guys just got back from
movie fights whoo well what uh what a
match I am tired
thank God they film right next door
people don't know but our studio is in
the same studio where you know drug is a
phantom is and hey great job on the
outcome I managed the outcome talk about
convenience
unfortunately because I was prepping for
movie fights running late - Ralph breaks
the internet trailer number DOS but I
want to check this trailer out do you
yes I do you want to see the first movie
I've been waiting for this because I
really wanted a taste before I started
watching the first bit I think it's
important to watch sequel trailers
before they're watch the first movie I
feel like you actually want to go back
and watch it I think the new trends
should be the Hollywood releases the
sequel firstly you're guaranteed a
prequel at Part 1 and then we're all a
little bit lost until the prequel comes
out Zack Lee that's how I like to do
things before we do that I wanted to
tell you guys but this is not a
sponsored video I just wanna keep
mentioning that because I think it earns
bonus points when you shot something now
it's like you're not getting paid to do
it I'm selling out yeah it's great isn't
it we are on the Stardust app at the
real rejects over there guys and we post
so much over there most pretty much
daily and I don't know we just really
love using the app we notice the
community has really been growing wants
to thank you - everyone has been
following us sometimes we do like a
little micro sketch we have fun with
them
30-second reactions to TV shows and
movies and trailers it's a total blast
and we really appreciate you follow
there's a lot of big people over there
but only follow us and John Bailey let's
do it
[Applause]
[Music]
No
Oh animal deaths details
[Music]
electric water this room yeah
[Music]
yes it is maple there's no law saying
best friends have to have the same
dreams
[Music]
this is what's called the darknet are
you sure this not look at his little
brother what are you doing huh hmm
the reason I came to your neck of the
face yeah there's a face in your neck I
[Music]
can't wait for the director to release
the Unrated cutter this movie yeah it'll
be just horrible and obscene and rupture
DVD oh gosh I it's so excited for when
that day finally rolls are ready man
Ralph buys a bunch of the legal viagra
knives and guns and stuff you know I've
had a lot of faith in this movie and I
know that people have kind of been
clowning on the past trailers for this
film like stupid Mogi movie I got a
weird accent now let's talk star you
know I haven't seen the emoji movie I've
seen a lot of trailers for that I heard
it's great looks like a better version
of that just the trailers look like a
better trailer of the emoji movie yeah
what it was nice this time to actually
get a sense for the plot and why they're
going to the Internet yeah it's just one
little nugget about we got a fixed
vanilla peas game you know yeah it's a
worthwhile adventure and there's an
actual theme here this time because I
know you haven't seen the first record
Ralph what I know really I feel like
every time we've done together clearly I
always tried to hide it but not always
try to hide it and BSR away on the
internet so dirty not today yeah that's
a really good theme to explore because
the first one you know when they really
dive into the thematic elements of that
one especially towards the finale of man
I'm talking just tear fest on my end
try not to really good way to it I was
just like bawling and here this little
slit moment cuz a lot of why I think
people have been saying this looks like
a Moche movie beyond the concept of the
Internet and all that is it just seems
like jokes every second jokes every
second while there's a lot of that
kinetic energy there seem to be an
actual heart here there seem to be an
actual thing to explore here with the
friendship of vanellope and ralph of how
she has different dream she has
different goals just because they're
best buds
doesn't mean they're always gonna be in
alignment for what they want for their
future you know Ralph might just want to
stay here Kate
and just live the life and stay comfy
where it seems like vanellope wants to
explore and do different things beyond
what she was programmed to do yeah maybe
that'll be the arc of the movie maybe by
the end she will learn to embrace having
to move on a sugar rush or maybe Ralph
becomes an app maybe and then he can
live in the phone with the emojis
crossover oh my gosh why has Disney /
marbles left Star Wars not hired us yeah
I know
jeepers Christ I mean it was nice to
have a reason for going to the internet
because I feel like that was the big
complaint of the last couple trailers is
just sort of like cool but why other
than video games are online as well I
mean yeah I remember like brief stuff
something they're not having a Saban LP
but I feel like the trailer actually
made this look like a real movie and see
is the budget gimmicks about them going
to the internet and hey look we're
talking about the internet here this is
out of their realm yeah yeah and that
joke in and of itself el show did that
ages ago yeah like it's not ultimately
that fresh of a joke so it's nice to see
them you know at least fleshing it out
here and I don't know about you well
when they go to that like hellish racing
game I was getting serious cyberpunk
2077 really yeah just like in the
aesthetics I wonder if you know that
joke about the dog being killed will fly
by well with some people you know who
would not fly by well with the ASPCA
yep yeah that was based on a real animal
death oh my girlfriend I don't know show
respond to that joke even in animation
even an animation man just killing dogs
for a joke come on hang cool no add your
glory might hate that joke - it's in the
trailer it's crazy wait wait a minute if
you slowed down this trailer if you go
150
he's on an iPad yeah well in a human
office it appears maybe she does become
it happy maybe we're gonna figure the
[ __ ] out of this movie right now
trailers today just spoil way too much
man
I mean even though I didn't really like
what I saw her just thought image was
just 10 dancing and realized what it was
on maybe he just got it to some other
internet thing you were too invested
man I think they threw in the bit about
the dark web too because I think a lot
of people have been joking about oh god
I was gonna find some dirt I feel like
is a simple thing for them to explore
here as if they like jackin to some
internet feed that's on age-restricted
now that's a simple way to filter it out
here not that I always prevents
everything but it's an easier way to go
oh no wonder they're not going into the
darker spots and uh you know yeah I mean
yeah onion we're all the way and I mean
that's something I wonder about too cuz
that's just territory that like we all
if you know what the Deep Web is you
know what kind of things are said to
inhabit it and so I sit here and think
well are they going to be able to make
that fit this world without us being
like why isn't this so much more
sinister but I think that's actually
like I'm not bummed that they're trying
it but I think your idea is actually
pretty fun because most of the kids
today who have grown up with computers
probably know the frustration of trying
to navigate the internet on an
age-restricted computer because there's
stuff that inevitably you can't get to
that's totally a program anyway like
they could have used that as a joke and
a safeguard but you know whatever and we
got rickrolled you internet classic man
yeah it's like I Rick Astley must just
be so happy to live in modern times
where he's one of the greatest internet
meme yeah because that's been going on
for for so long now just people randomly
throwing in that music video and you
think you're watching something else
yep's were the kids right here love rick
astley oh yeah especially when he covers
Metallica oh hey let's let's give a
patient the day shout out to a patron
who I barely know but is apparently one
of John's friends that's right
Tiana Hicks what's up T - this is like I
imagine she's so well John shouting her
out I'm gonna try to go to John's
Facebook and see if I could find her see
if I can find her you shot her out while
I do my thing Tiana what's up how's
things going in Idaho Tiana just moved
to Idaho so that's cool but you know
what I watched this trailer and I saw a
lot of us in this trailer you know it's
like the way I carry you around on my
shoulder a lot the way we hop back and
forth between each other's different
video games the way in which we're at a
crossroads about you know where we want
to go in our lives is best best friends
so uh sure yeah oh damn I found her she
fine yeah yes he was pretty funny he's
dating her
no not why not cuz she just moved to
Idaho but she's a patron my way yeah ask
her out okay hey well you won't go out
whenever you visit town or whenever I
have enough time to make it Idaho
I'm sure we could get into some trouble
you know maybe go catch a spooky flick
or something you're the kind of girl job
would fall in love with it's possible
you never know I am a man of many tastes
and flavors don't say that
I'm not I didn't yeah everybody saw it I
didn't say anything
all right well Tiana I'm glad I could
put a face to the name you seem like a
very talented woman she is actually I
mean if she like paints she like
restores furniture she I get all that
photos yeah totally she writes and all
kinds of things come back to couch hope
you're doing well though say hi to
little one subscribe to the reject
nation please click that notification
bell on our patreon we do TV reactions
and Q&A s also more importantly follow
us on the stardust app link in the
description box and pin comment thanks
for watching guys